hey guys it's November first which means
this crazy here is almost over I'm
chastity covering for Jess let's jump in
some new shall we first up we got a hint
about Nintendo switches price and launch
lineup Nintendo won't officially
announce more key details about the
switch until January but President
tatsumi kimishima has offered a
high-level take on two key areas price
and launch lineup in terms of pricing
Commission has said during an earnings
briefing that the console will be priced
in line with what you'd expect from a
Nintendo console however given that the
switch is something of a new idea in
gaming it's a console mobile hybrid it's
not so easy to compare to any past
Nintendo system for reference that we
start at two hundred and fifty dollars
while the wii u debuted at three hundred
dollars as for games support Nintendo's
only confirmed switch game is the legend
of zelda breath of the wild in the
switches announcement video we did see
teasers for new or updated versions of
Mario Kart 8 and splatoon as well as
that mysterious 3d Mario game Nintendo
caution that the trailer only showed
short glimpse as a representative
gameplay to demonstrate the liberating
nature of the Nintendo switch home
gaming system as for third party support
videos for Skyrim and NBA 2k games were
also shown in the trailer but these
games are not officially confirmed for
the console Ubisoft is bringing just
dance 2017 to the switch while dozens of
third-party developers have signed up to
support the console these include
Activision Electronic Arts Warner
Brothers Square Enix Konami and Capcom
Nintendo will officially announce the
switches price launch lineup and specs
on January 12th during an online
presentation the company has said not to
expect any major news about the console
until then next up another somber leaked
new overwatch art for sombra appeared on
blizzard's store just ahead of blizzcon
an image of sombra was found on the
server for blizzards official overwatch
merch store the new overwatch character
is expected to be announced at blizzcon
2016 this week the image is signed by
John Paul adoro who is listed as a
blizzard overwatch illustrator concept
artist and character designer on art
station although it has since been
removed the image has been reposted on
MJ via reddit sombra has shown standing
on the hand of a giant domnic with
threads of energy licking her hands to
the ominous fingers this suggests she is
exerting some sort of control over the
giant robot which could translate to
gameplay in interesting ways
although Blizzard hasn't officially
detailed somber yet fans have speculated
she'll be a hacker and advanced tech
user it's still unclear which class
grouping she'll fit into the pose she's
striking in the image is similar to the
one depicted in the previous league
which was featured on the same document
that also correctly detailed the
overwatch Halloween event lizard is
expected to show off the new overwatch
content during blizzcon 2016 which kicks
off on November fourth and last but not
least the first of the month means new
PlayStation and Xbox games for free
playstation plus an xbox live gold
members can now grab more free games
starting today there are a total of six
games up for grabs on Sony's systems but
thanks to cross by support ps4 owners
will get a total of four titles these
include the deadly Tower of monsters
everybody's gone to the rapture letter
quests remastered and pumped BMX plus
the Xbox one free be available today for
subscribers is super dungeon brothers
while in October carry over the
escapists is free until November 15 ps3
games available now for free include
costume quest to dirt 3 and pumped BMX
plus while the xbox 360 freebie is the
secret of monkey island special edition
you can check out the full lineup for
November PS Plus and games with gold
titles on gamespot com let me know your
thoughts on today's stories in the
comments below Jess will be back later
next week I promise but here's a Psyduck
for your troubles thanks for joining me
and I'll see you tomorrow
you